what fresh hell is this
get ready pledges that scream queens is
coming back for season two and ET was
with the returning stars at PaleyFest
where we got their reactions to a little
rumor that's flying around there's a
rumor Harry Styles might be joining the
cast next Tuesday no I have I heard that
I have so many young friends of mine
like out of the blue calling me all the
time I'm like why are you calling me all
of a sudden and of course it's like they
just they're just kind of like hey maybe
I can visit you so what can I say
okay first of all I think I started that
rumor so but I I don't know I talked to
Ryan the other day and he didn't give me
any hints but I'm pretty sure that I
started it whoops
come on Harry because you're definitely
cute and hopefully he's with zany now
would you be done for a Denis Harry
Styles romance to the rumor that he
might be joining the cast I would be all
about it
I mean Denis will be all about not neezy
whoa that's gonna start nothing don't
start nothin I don't know maybe I'm the
only person that's not super into one
direction but I mean I'd be into it I
love Nick so actually my 15 year old
sister keeps sending me articles about
that and I'm like just because you keep
sending me this article doesn't make it
true I mean I hope it's true too but
yeah my sister is like you it'd only be
cool if appearing styles with on scream
queens I'm like thanks a lot but nobody
tells me anything
I'm the realize number five like
literally so that nobody tells me
anything
um I'd be fine with Harry Styles writing
that's not really rude
I'd be really happy with Harry Styles
writing that'd be great
I'm gonna go ask Leah where she found
this information out I've only just
hearing this now
and so I don't know anything about that
so I mean he's welcome but nothing
official to announce should we start
another rumor yeah what else like oh
there we go
Lena Dunham seems like gonna be on
scream queens we'll see how far that one
Ken